[MUSIC]
Welcome to the Stanford MBA session on
preparing for a career in consulting.
My name's Lisa Jane Angela,
I'm a director of MBA Admissions at
the Stanford Graduate School of Business
as well as an alumna of the program.
And I am super excited to host this
panel today, because both before and
after business school, I was a consultant.
But today I'm joined by some of my fellow
GSB alumni, who are currently working in
the consulting industry and they will
share some of their perspectives with you.
So, just a little bit about what
to expect from today's event.
Really, the whole purpose of today's event
is to allow you an opportunity to engage
with our community to learn a little
bit more about the GSB experience and
how it can really help enable
your future aspirations.
So we'll talk a little bit about
where this journey can take you.
You'll have an opportunity
to meet our panelists.
I'll start us off with some Q&A.
Some questions there
that we have prepared and
really we want to spend the majority
of time answering your questions.
So at any point in today's session,
please feel free to go to that Q&A box and
pop in a question that you'd like to ask.
Our panelists will We'll try to get
to as many questions as we can.
If you see a question that someone else
has asked that you particularly like,
just click on that thumbs up symbol and
that will vote that question
up towards the top.
So let's get started.
Let's start with where will
your journey take you.
Now with the Stanford MBA I think
the possibilities are endless.
But here you see a few high level stats
for one of our recent graduating classes.
So for the class of 2020,
91% of our students had job offers
three months after graduation.
There were 445 different organizations
that were recruiting our MBA students.
And 71 of our MBA students made
a career pivot, whether that was
an industry function, location or
some combination of those three.
As you can see year in, year out
consulting remains in the top five
industries and functional areas
that our graduates go into.
We are very proud that for
several years now we had record
compensation within the, MBA marketplace.
For the class of 2020,
those who are graduating,
the median base salary
was $156,000 that year.
And if you look at those graduates
who went into consulting,
the median base salary was even
higher at 165,000 per year.
But let's spend a little bit of time on
talking to some of these consultants and
meeting some of our alumni.
So we have a wonderful group
who is joining us today.
Some who were working in consulting
before business school and
really use this experience
to accelerate their careers.
And others who perhaps are looking
to pivot in Into consulting and
use the GSB experience
as a way to do that.
And so I've each of the panelist
briefly introduce yourselves.
We're going in order that we see here,
and Ryan we'll have you start please.
>> Thanks, Lisa.
Hello, everyone,
I graduated GSB class of 2020.
So interesting to see this statistics that
Lisa was just showing about my class.
Before the GSB,
I'll start just undergrad went to American
University studying International Studies.
I stayed in Washington DC doing strategy
and management consulting at Deloitte.
Then after the GSB, I moved to New York
where I've had a focus on design and
innovation, consulting still at
Deloitte and focusing on healthcare.
>> Great, thank you, Ryan.
Hi everyone.
My name is Rachel.
I'm originally from Sacramento, California
and I went to Duke University for
undergrad where I studied public policy.
After graduating I spent five years
in Chicago, I worked in consumer
packaged goods doing brand management and
then went to Stanford for my MBA.
I interned in consulting and then accepted
full time position with Bain afterwards.
I've been there for about two years.
And in my time so far I focus on our
private equity group as well as utilities.
>> Hi everyone, I'm Andre.
I graduated with Rachel and Tiny team,
started I was a biotechnology
engineering undergrad in Mexico.
So started off my career in more like
research in the medical space and
then pivoted into consulting
right before the GSB.
I was part of the McKinsey Nairobi
office in Kenya focusing on social
sector consulting, especially in
us kind of the DSB experience to
continue that track now that.
I returned to McKinsey teams ago,
so it's great to be here.
>> Awesome.
Thanks, Andrea.
Hi everybody.
My name is Jonathan I graduated
from the GSB in 2016.
Coming out of undergrad at Yale,
I spent most of my time in the clean
tech and clean energy space.
So I developed renewable energy projects.
For about two years and
then spent about two and a half years,
developing a lot of the operational
processes to manage
the electrical grid given renewables
coming online at McKinsey.
So post business school, I shifted
to consulting after Business School.
So at McKinsey I focused on a lot of
the same topics that I did beforehand but
just in consulting.
So I work primarily with utility
clients clean energy, clean tech and
a lot on sustainability as well.
>> Good evening and Scott.
I'm from San Diego California.
Before the GSB I worked
in healthcare I work for
healthcare nonprofit in San Diego
did a mixture of commercialized.
Using innovative healthcare technologies
worked in tele obstetrics and
tele orthopedics,
as well as doing some lobbying.
It was during the passage
of the Affordable Care Act.
He also worked in health care
policy at the GSB was looking for
a way to blend my interest in industry
with my interest in policy and
ended up pursuing public
sector consulting.
I'm now at BCG and
I've worked on a variety of
different public sector projects.
>> Hi all, this is Casey.
I went to Stanford as an undergrad and
then came back for my MBA graduated,
gosh, more than ten years ago now,
which is unbelievable to me.
But definitely used my time at
Stanford to do a few pivots.
So I had worked in Financial Services for
visa prior to coming to Stanford.
And it actually been the client with a
consulting firm working on the other side
and realized that that was what I
thought would be a more exciting path.
And so I came to the GSB and
found out that there was this company
called Bain that got me really excited.
And I use it as an opportunity to
both pivot into consulting but
also have been with our healthcare
practice for most of the last decade.
And that's where I spend the majority
of my time, including the last year and
a half have been working with
COVID testing providers.
So you can imagine how exciting this
these last 12 months have been.
Looking forward to talking with you more.
>> Well, thank you all for
the introductions.
Maybe before we dive into
consulting specifically just
a higher level broad question that
some of you might want to answer.
Why did you decide to do an MBA and
why specifically at Stanford?
>> So for me, coming from being
in consulting and then I'm really
starting before that,
I called out my undergrad studies because
I had no business backing,
in consulting and in several industries.
They bring in a multidisciplinary
approach and so they're looking for
those that have different backgrounds.
But it meant that my
business core function
focus analysis needed to be beefed up.
That's one of the reasons I then
started looking at MBAs in general and
then for me, in particular,
Stanford and the GSB.
There are really the home to
what we call design thinking
starting from the customer viewpoint.
What a customer needs,
motivations, frustrations and
using that as inspiration for innovation
tying that into new business models.
We're in the heart of Silicon Valley.
So, different ways of engaging
with customers that all been
attracted me to the GSB.
And as I learned more, it became the
community that I saw among students that
then really excited me and said, this
is the place I want to get my MBA from.
So it's kind of a ladder of
different things coming down
the pike
>> I actually tried really hard to
not come back to Stanford.
Having been an undergrad I was like,
all right, I've already done that.
That was amazing, but
I should really go somewhere else.
But when I decided, I wanted to make the
decision on the merits of the school and
Stanford was just head and
shoulders above all the other options.
Especially, for me what really stood
out was classes that were focused on
leadership development, really thinking
about not just how to develop like a true
general manager mindset.
By really honing that with
leadership skills, touchy feely,
organizational design, like the things
that I was starting to realize.
In my career pre MBA, were really making
the difference between people who were
just okay at their jobs and
the ones who really excelled.
And to me Stanford was just head and
shoulders above all the other
options on that dimension.
>> Okay, let me chime in
with another question here.
So, I know some of you were pivoting into
consulting after your GSB experience.
For those of you who made that pivot, how
did the GSB help you with that transition?
Whether it was from, academic
coursework or career support or clubs,
alumni students, how did the GSB enable
that transition into consulting?
>> I can speak here.
So as I mentioned, I worked in consumer
packaged goods before business school.
But knew I wanted to do a summer
internship in consulting.
And Stanford had a lot of resources.
You get a little taste of it
with some of the academic work,
I would say the clubs are great.
But to me the biggest resource
is actually my fellow students.
Stanford students are probably
the most giving and
thoughtful students in the world.
And I just reached out to all
of my classmates who were former
consultants to do case prep.
And they all gave me so much time.
I can't even tell you how much time we
spent in the library just going through
different cases.
And I think that was actually probably
the most valuable resource that I
had at Stanford for my fellow students.
>> And Jonathan or others who also
made that transition into consulting,
how do you think the GSB
experience helped you enable that?
>> Yeah, so at least I think on my part,
I think a similar story.
I was working on a utility just
before coming to business school.
>> And what are folks that were
very good at their jobs, but
maybe not the most motivated to try and
go do new things.
And so one of the things I wanted to do
coming into the GSB was kind of figuring
out how to work with and motivate
others to do really amazing things.
And so for me, the GSB is Arbuckle
Leadership Program was really wonderful.
So I did that my second year at the GSB.
And then that's been really helpful for
me in consulting because a lot of
our day to day work is around.
How you influence and
inspire clients to go further and
kind of push further
beyond their boundaries.
>> Okay, for those of you who were coming
from a consulting background already,
and maybe using the GSB to
accelerate your career,
what do you think you got out of this
experience that you wouldn't have received
otherwise if you had just continued,
working through and skipped an MBA?
>> I can jump in here.
So I was talking to you, I see a much
smaller pivot but to pivot between within
consulting from being like a generalist
to them focusing only on public and
social sector consulting.
And Stanford specifically gave me
an opportunity to first do a joined MBA
with AMA in education within the two
years which was very important to me.
And also within the GSB was able
to align especially to the social
innovation kind of side of the classes
that we were able to take.
And that really kind of gave me another
perspective focusing on emerging markets
and a little bit more of the social
pieces that I was trying to develop.
So definitely prepared me to then come
back to McKinsey in a more like expert
specialised role than I would have been
able to do without taking the time to go
back to school again.
>> All right, I'm pivoting again.
I know consulting might be new for a lot
of the people who are tuning in today.
So, how would you all describe
the typical day in the life of or
week in the life of a consultant
who wants to shed some light there?
What its to actually work in the industry?
>> Again I can start off.
Obviously different story
pre-COVID than post COVID.
Currently, what it looks like is
obviously a lot of Zoom calls.
And during those, there's a mix of
client calls but also problem solving or
brainstorming depending on what term
you use with your team and colleagues,
but also with internal experts or
external experts to the firm.
Basically, what you're trying to do in
your day to day is have some sort of
specific problem that you say your client
has that is really like top of mind and
taking so much energy from them.
So, you're there to kind of provide
a little bit of that surge support to help
them get through either that bump or
to get to the next level depending if it's
a kind of positive or
negative situation a little bit.
And before it used to also
involve a lot of travel,
might pick up back again
once you are like post your
MBA will probably be in another normal.
But that has been a little bit
of a different reality for
the past couple of months.
I don't know if anybody
else wants to chime in.
>> Yep, how have you balanced
the workload and the travel and
kind of normal study state time at
the client site versus in your office?
How does that look even?
>> Yeah, I mean, I'll say consulting
there's never a dull moment.
And in consulting for
sure you wake up in the morning and
you don't know exactly how
that day is going to unfold.
And at least for me, that is still 10
years into the job what gets me going,
I love that aspect of it.
And then, I have two kids now one
is four years old and one's two.
And so, we have had to just make some
real boundaries around my job gets can
take a lot of my time but we have really
clear I call them the golden hours.
So, when we wake up in the morning until
8 like those are my kids times they just
don't do other stuff and
the same thing at the end of the day 6 to
8 I just don't touch work, my laptop etc.
And it's been a really good forcing
function and really well received within
not just my company and being but
with my clients, right?
They actually do respect that we're
all human and have families and
other obligations outside of work and it's
It's refreshing to be able to just have
those conversations as to humans, like,
hey, here are my boundaries or limits.
And I've found that there have been
times when this job has been busier than
other times.
But throughout those kinds
of honest communicated with
conversations have been what
have broken through and
made sure that it was kind
of the best of all worlds.
So, 10 years, and it's still going great.
I love it.
>> What are the great things
about consulting too?
Is it that there's more ability to
control how that lifestyle might look for
you than you might get in some
other industries like that?
I joined BCG with a classmate at the GSB
who convinced me that we should apply to
BCG together, and we've kind of tracked
each other's careers all the way through.
And we've taken a very different routes
in terms of what we're interested in,
but then also how we balance travel or
how we think about the role of the job and
our wife.
So she's married,
expecting her first child, and
has a dog and optimizes for,
she doesn't want to travel.
She's also, she's a extrovert.
So she loves being in the office.
She loves those big group settings.
She's been able to create that setting for
herself.
I don't live with anyone,
don't have a dog, and I'm an introvert.
So I'm able to arrange my day around the
kind of things that give me energy, which
plenty of alone time, to think through a
problem and then talk to people about it.
I also wanted to maximize the travel.
So, I lived out of a suitcase for
two years, and
I bounced around the world doing projects,
and it was a great adventure.
And it sounded like the worst
thing in the world to her.
So I think one of the great things,
they were at the same firm,
started in the same office.
So I think what's great is that you have
the ability to really control how you want
the career to look for you.
>> And I'll just add, Scott,
that's totally true over
the course of the career too.
In my first years in consulting,
I wanted the same thing.
I wanted to be traveling all the time.
I went and did six months in Paris.
I did the whole global thing.
And then, when I want to change, and
the great thing about my job was
that it was able to change with me.
And that was sort of
an unexpected benefit.
I don't know but I was like solving for
that when I was at the GSB applying for
consulting jobs.
It's been great.
>> All right, maybe switching gears to
talk a little bit about recruiting.
So, some of you may have gone
through the recruiting process for
consulting jobs relatively recently as you
were finishing up your GSB experience.
Others of you might actually be involved
in the recruiting process now and
helping to interview and screen resumes
and things within your respective firms.
How could you shed some light on what
the recruiting process within consulting
looks like?
How people might best prepare for
that or come up to speed and
be successful in those interviews and
in that recruiting process?
>> I think Rachel was hinting at this when
she was talking about the benefits of
the GSB.
As much as you can do in
terms of practicing cases,
so each firm has a little bit of
a different style of how we do cases.
But overall, there's a case study
involved across all of our firms.
So, taking the time to really practice
with a peer, so not only yourself trying
to do it and kind of self reflect,
I think that is really, really helpful.
My only small tip would be also like don't
overdo it to a point where it sounds
scripted because there's also a little
bit of a tipping point that is reached at
some point.
But I don't know, Rachel,
do you have other other tips as well?
>> Yeah, no,
I mean that's the right advice.
One thing just to start with that's
really nice about the GSB is that they
actually protect your first,
I think it's maybe two months at school.
So, it's really nice because it allows you
to get acquainted with being a student.
Again, and you really don't
have to think about recruiting.
And then once that does begin,
I think it's great to talk to your fellow
classmates who have done consulting,
figure out what they really liked
about the job, how that matches what
your career ambitions are, and
then spend time doing a lot of case craft.
But honestly, that's the crux of
the interview is you won't be doing cases.
And so, it gets really important to
figure out the structure of that.
But as Andrea said, don't overdo it,
don't become too robotic.
Always approach it as if you were
actually in the job yourself day one.
What are the big questions
that you're trying to answer?
And then go from there.
>> All right, we'll turn to maybe some
questions from our audience here.
And so we have one that says, for someone
who's looking to pivot into consulting and
maybe doesn't have as much day to
day insight, could you let us know,
what's the part of your role
that you both enjoy and
what is the part of your role in
consulting that you least enjoy?
>> I can start us off.
And I think as the panel has
already started to highlight,
the consulting journey for
each person is so individual and
you can tweak different dynamics of it.
So, I imagine my answers will
be very different than others.
The thing that I like the most
about consulting that excites
me each day is working with my team,
the Elisa Deloitte and
I believe so in other consulting firms.
We're very team oriented,
and we work on a problem together
bringing different perspectives.
And that approach, I feel has allowed
me to continue to grow every day.
I'm learning something
new from my teammates.
It's also, as I've moved up in consulting,
then you play more of a manager role, and
that also comes with its own stretching
of how do I make the best environment for
the team members around me?
And that, I think, is a really fun,
challenging, energizing problem and
to constantly be working through.
So I think that's my highlight.
And maybe we do highlights around, or
one other person just highlights before we
go to what's more challenging in the role
>> I love the fact that I get to dig
into problems that excite me, and
I know what excites me is going to
be different from someone else.
But I, just like at the GSB, right?
I love the fact that I got to take
whatever classes I wanted in my second
year and including across these
three courses is same in consulting.
I get to dig into how do state
governments set their budgets?.
And that's the thing that
really gets me excited.
Everybody else may think it's a snoozer,
but
everybody gets to kind of find
the thing that excites them.
I really, I like the fact that
the problems are, there's stuff that I
care about and stuff that feels like
it matters, and I got to pick it.
>> Any other?
>> Relationships that I've been building
not just, so I get to have my
Bain family here, my teams and
my colleagues I've gotten to know
over time and worked with closely.
But then, I also have my clients who at
this point I've got asked somebody asked
in the Q and A like your clients,
was like yeah, they're mine,
they're people that I've built
really deep relationships with.
And I know their families, I know their
aspirations, I give them career advice.
It's a very deep relationship.
And I love that about consulting that
I've had the opportunity to build those
out over time.
>> Anything on the other side of the coin?
Rachel, sorry, you're going to chime in?
>> I mean, it's similar to
what other folks have said.
But the problems that we're facing
are problems that are challenging enough
that in others parts are like, okay,
we need someone else to come in and help.
And to me, that's really motivating,
and really exciting.
It's also you're really focused
on cracking this one problem.
I remember when I was working in CPG,
before business school, I felt like,,
there were a ton of things on my plate,
my attention constantly got
drawn to different places.
And it didn't allow me to like, really,
like focus on sort of some of the biggest
issues that I really wanted to tackle and
I love that I get to be really
dedicated to that in this role.
And like everyone said to I really like
how we have this case team environment
where everyone's really in it together.
And the collaboration with the client
is really inspiring as well.
So there's a lot of elements in
this job that are really fantastic.
>> Jonathan,
did you have anything you wanted to add or
do you want to go to the dark side?
>> I think it's been sad but
I think the people element as well,
like many of the same folks that you'd
be going to business school with develop
great relationships will be
on your consulting teams.
Or there'll be the ones that are your
peers when you're in the office on Fridays
or during COVID maybe every day.
But when you're in the office on Fridays,
they'll be the ones that you're hanging
out with and it's not something that
he'll probably see in any other job.
>> How about some of the downsides or some
of the things that you're least excited
about within the consulting industry?
Just to be fair and
look at the other side of the coin.
>> Since I started as a photographer, I
can start on the other side too, which for
me, I think, as I am thinking about
consulting versus what's next,
one of the things I've
felt in consulting is.
We had, as Richard was talking like,
dedicated on one core
problem all together, but
then we I understandably hand it off for
an implementation to happen.
Or for further thinking to happen or for
it to be embedded in your organization.
But I often then don't see
the reach the customer side of it.
So if we're thinking upstream,
I have a lot of focus there.
I'm wondering for me, the next question
I'm doing with my own career is.
What does that look like downstream?
How do I like that the implementation part
the owning something start to finish.
We're owning start to finish
the answer to some problems, but
thinking about the full
life-cycle of an organization and
thinking about the organizational
beyond that, and so on.
A lot of the classes of the GSB have
exposed me to that level of thinking that
I'm now curious about,
which I have less insight into.
And that would be, I think one of my
challenges with consulting for right now.
>> I think the other thing they were
all like tiptoeing around like,
it's long hours.
It's part of the industry,
I think across the sector is just
how consulting has been set up.
It has been improving and
hopefully it keeps on improving.
But it is a demanding job because of
what everybody has said of we're solving
problems that were we brought in because
somebody else couldn't solve them.
So therefore, it's usually a big task.
>> I will say though,
I know I'm at a point where I think
my clients work harder than I do.
So it just there's a time
out there where [LAUGH] and
I definitely get to take sabbaticals and
time off because of the project based
work a little bit more easily than I think
some of my clients who are in industry.
So there's a shining light out there and
I would also say just.
There is a period of time where people are
like okay, so you're doing consulting for
now but
like What's your real career going to be?
And I would just say like as Scott and
Ryan another subset like lots of
different ways that you enter and
sometimes exit consulting but I,
have times I've had to say like,
no, I really enjoy consulting.
This is my career like, and
there's an identity there and
a path there and there's a lot of joy and
fulfillment there.
So, sometimes that's a big question that
people have that you end up feeling a lot.
>> All right, we have another
question here from our audience,
given the location of Stanford right
there in the hardest Silicon Valley and
this hotbed of innovation and
all sorts of different things going on.
What swayed you to consulting or helped
you to stay the course in consulting if
you are already in it,
versus maybe moving to private equity or
venture capital or
technology or something else?
How did the location kind
of impact your experience?
And maybe make you even more
sad about consulting, or
expose you to different
things that help you now?
>> I think it was, and this also
vary depending on class by class,
every class is a little
bit of a different.
My personal experience
with like Stanford and
consulting was, it wasn't,
especially in during the first year.
It was not the highest, let's say,
ranked preference that I would say like,
what did you do before going to Stanford?
And my answer would be I was in McKinsey.
And the answer was usually like kind of,
because people are much more excited about
the I started and I did a startup or
I was doing this like weird thing in
the middle of nowhere and stuff like that.
And that was much more energizing and
attention grabbing,
especially in the first couple months.
Once we started getting closer to summer
internships that quickly shifted.
But to the implied question of like,
was it easy to stay the course?
For me?
It wasn't like I definitely felt a little
bit more the pressure of expanding and
like looking again and
rethinking everything what is out there.
In the end, I didn't find something that
was as exciting to me as continuing down
the consulting path like to what Casey was
saying of like that being my career so
I decided to stay.
But it was definitely the signaling
around it is definitely on like expand,
explore, search, like do new and
different things.
So there was a little bit
of going against that.
>> Yeah, I did not come to the GSB
thinking I was going to be a consultant
when I left And even probably right up
till about a month before graduation,
I didn't think I would be
a consultant when I left and
try it a lot of different things.
I think Stanford's location meant that I
had the ability to try a lot of different
things and to try them seriously.
So I work for a venture fund.
We founded a social enterprise in Nepal.
I've worked for local government,
I tried a lot of different things,
in addition to trying consulting.
And I think that the location
of the Stanford network gave me
the data that I needed to be able to say,
okay, I've,
I thought all these things
could be interested.
I tried all of them now I have the
information I need to know that consulting
was the right thing for me,
but it certainly wasn't,
didn't didn't come with that mission.
But Stanford is a place that
encourages experimentation I loved.
I don't know if it's the same approach but
a lot of the career counseling process,
they're very much said, No, don't go
reconfirm things you already know.
Try things you don't know
about to get the information
about what you do you don't like and
what works for you.
And I'm really glad I
ended up in consulting and
also really glad that Silicon Valley
meant that it was really
easy to try a bunch of
other things in parallel.
>> Go ahead.
>> Just to add to that, too, about Sam for
providing the opportunities to
test waters and a lot of spaces.
I think that's absolutely true.
And because of its location, you get kind
of CEOs of high tech companies coming in
to talk to you and also coursework if
anyone's interested in creating their
own company, their startup garage.
And I had a couple of friends
go through startup garage, and
most of them realize, what, I don't
think I'm going to be a founder and
went on to find jobs at other companies.
For me, one thing that was,
I don't know kind of won me over for
consulting is kind of what
Ryan alluded into too.
Is you can start in consulting, but still
pivot into another industry afterwards.
I really feel there isn't really a
downside of starting in consulting unless
you know exactly what you want to do and
it's not consulting.
It gives you a really good opportunity
to explore and grow a lot.
And the skills that you'll gain
from consulting similar to Stanford
will help you in whatever career that
you want to do afterwards if you
decide eventually you do want to
be industry or role focused so.
>> All right,
we have another question here.
Are there any must take courses or
experiences that really helped you build
your strategic thinking or
leadership skills for consulting?
>> I can take that on Lisa.
I don't think that there were any
in particular that were must take.
So I would say that there's two that
are just general GSB must takes that I
would recommend.
So touchy feely, which is also
known as interpersonal dynamics,
which is a great class will help you.
One just generally in all
of your relationships but
probably also help you relate to
your clients as well and consulting.
And then the other one that I found to be
incredibly helpful was managing growing
enterprises which just helped you have and
roleplay a lot of difficult
conversations that you might have.
With clients or with some folks on your
team as well, certainly other classes,
maybe that are helpful.
But, I think for all of the firms
that are represented here,
there's a fair amount of on boarding and
training in terms of hard skills.
So I'd probably focus a bit
more on the interpersonal
soft stuff while you're at the GSB.
>> I just have to say I'm relieved to hear
that the two classes I was going to say
are still being told by graduating
recently that makes me feel warm and
fuzzy and not so old.
So that's very cool.
[LAUGH] Two thumbs up for
MGE and interpersonal dynamics.
And then I would just emphasize that part
about, because I saw a few questions
in the chat about non-profit backgrounds
or less traditional backgrounds.
I think all the firms are focused on
making sure that the hard skills you need
like how to do a piano or how to use
Excel, you're going to get those skills on
the job, the training is excellent and
consulting.
So the time of the GSB is precious for
a lot of more GM oriented and
touchy feely types of classes I think.
>> The other classes or experiences
that you draw upon today, anyone else?
>> As in general I'd just say take
the risk when you're at the GSB.
So because of great non disclosure and
because of the fact that the student body
is incredibly supportive of each other.
Take the harder version of the course if
you're on the fence between the base level
and the harder level of marketing.
Take the advanced course or
you're not certain about that
across the street court.
Take the risk.
It's an incredibly safe environment.
I think that the times when I pushed
myself into those more advanced courses or
I took the,
international policy course across the
street that I had no business being in.
Were the ones that weren't where
I actually learned the most
>> And the favorites?
>> I can build on that too.
I mean, I think one thing that's
great about Stanford is yes,
you do have classes that are set up
with the typical case structure,
but you have a lot of
different formats too.
And some of the other
formats is what I love a lot.
I took a class my second year
called leadership perspective,
where we just brought in really inspiring
leaders from different industries.
To tell us about their career journey and
how they thought about their
leadership style over the course of it.
And at the end, I had the opportunity to
sit down reflect what kind of leader do I
want to be tomorrow in five
years in ten years, and
to me that's a really great opportunity.
I also kind of like MGE as Jonathan said,
there's a class called managing it typical
conversations and
it's all about role playing.
And sometimes you don't realize how much
you learn from actually just trying to do
it yourself.
It's different to think something
to actually try speaking it and
I loved those classes at Stanford.
And then lastly,
there's a lot of design oriented classes.
Right, I think you had
mentioned that earlier,
I took a class called Equity by Design.
And I've actually directly used some of
the principles I learned that class and
the diversity equity
inclusion [INAUDIBLE].
So, yeah,
Stanford offers very different formats, or
a lot of very different formats and
they're all really, valuable.
>> I'm curious if any of you were involved
in the consulting club during your time
on campus?
And if so, how that was that experience
and in addition to the consulting club,
what were some other helpful resources
that helped you with the recruiting?
I know you mentioned classmates and
such earlier but
are there any other things either
consulting club or other resources?
>> I feel the alumni network
deserves a mention as well.
I wanted to move geographies as
part of recruiting for consulting.
So, I called up the alumni
in Australia and said,
I'm interested in making
a move to Australia.
Can you help me through this process?
I think that was absolutely invaluable.
It's also great to be able to talk
to alumni from multiple firms.
To be able to get a sense for
how the different firms operate.
And so beyond the people that are on
campus there to help you and your peers.
Know that people who are part of a broader
community I found absolutely invaluable
throughout the process.
>> Does any of you rely on
career management advisors or
career management support during
your time there as you were
making this transition or deciding if you
wanted to stay in consulting or not or?
>> I ended up using the CMC
as what it's called.
I'll call it more of like a therapy
session around my career progression and
where I wanted to go,
which was some great listeners.
I've just like helping me verbalize out
loud where I wanted to track my career in
the short term and in the longer term and
then that meant actually for
my GSB experience.
So kind of taking it full circle, I found
them helpful in thinking through that.
And then I also went to a deck
because we're all central
on Stanford's campus and
the GSB is tucked in a corner.
I used what we call NBA twos when I was
an NBA ones, when I was a first year,
the second year is to kind of bounce
ideas back and forth as well.
So it was, if we think of lots of
different levels of people to engage,
I also found them useful.
You're surrounded by so many people all
thinking about those same questions.
>> We've talked a little bit about some of
the resources that folks have use as they
were thinking about
the consulting industry.
There's a question here if consulting
really as a focus at the GSB or
not, Andre, I think you've kind of
maybe highlighted that a little bit.
When you first arrived and how that
shifted over your time there as it got
closer to summer internships and such.
But did you feel that the school
tried to either push you towards or
push you away from consulting and is sort
of the gist of this question, did you?
>> I didn't feel that the school or the
class or the teachers themselves tried to
push me towards or
away from consulting or towards or
away from any other career I think a lot
of the conversation was focused on,
just more the concept of a leader that
I think Rachel was mentioning of,
what type of leader do you want to be?
Obviously, aligned with the the school's
[INAUDIBLE] as well like what type of
changes do you want to drive?
What good do you want to
bring to the world, etc.?
So that piece there was a lot of
focus on reflecting on that and
learning the skills to build towards that.
But I don't think at any point
there was a kind of industry poach.
Some of the classes,
I feel like do assume a little bit
of a private sector more like focus,
but there's also where I leaned on more of
like social innovation and all that track.
And a lot of the classes were like,
okay, if you were the CEO of this,
what would you do?
So, there is an assumption
of that type of career, but
not in a specific industry,
would be my personal experience.
>> All right, I see a question here.
Obviously, there are a lot
of different wonderful
consulting firms out there you work for
many of them.
There are also different types of
consulting even within various firms, too.
How did you find the right fit for
you, both the company and
the type of work that you're
doing within that company.
And are there different personality
types by firm or capabilities that firms
are looking for, tell me a little bit more
about that fit and finding your place?
>> I'll take a stab at this final
round sir, interesting one.
So, I think once upon a time we were
all recruiting for consulting, and
we're all kind of randomly
picking which ones we like and
we've all got our own
different personalities.
And I don't know that any of
the firms are necessarily looking for
different personalities, but
I do think the firms will have different
personalities that
resonate better with you.
And I think that during
the recruiting process,
you will find just what works better for
you?
That could both be the firm's actual
culture or it could also be who in
particular from the firm shows up for
that particular cultivation event.
So it's a little bit of
learning on your part, but
I certainly know that McKinsey is not out
there looking for a specific personality.
And, in fact, we're actually
looking to have be as inclusive and
work for as many different
types of folks as possible so
we can get as many different
voices as we make decisions and
make sure that we're representing our
clients and our clients customers as best
we can in these rooms where we're
making recommendations to them.
>> Ask just even from within your firms,
trying to figure out, do you want to be
more of a generalist or have a particular
industry focus or other area of expertise?
How did you navigate that?
Or how much time do you have to decide?
Or things like that,
that might be helpful for our audience.
>> Again, I mean, I think on that one,
it's probably a little bit up to you.
So, I think for all of our firms,
there's probably generalists, and
maybe certainly McKinsey there
are folks that are expert focus so
they may focus on a specific function or
industry.
Or particular growth area.
And so,
I know that McKinsey is really excited and
has this thing where you can kind of
do whatever you want to some extent.
They call it make your own McKinsey.
But, basically, if you are most excited
about doing clean technology work or
sustainability work, like I was,
you can focus on that either by
being a generalist or
being exclusively an expert on that topic.
And so, to some extent, it really just
comes down to what you want to do and
then trying to find the right
people at McKinsey, at least.
And I don't know how it works at the other
firms that are represented here.
You can try and make that particular the
patch work, but you really need to have
some conversations with different folks
to create some of those opportunities.
>> I will say consultants
are really good at aliteration, so
you've got Make Your Own McKinsey and
we have Build Your Own Bean,
but it's the same idea in consulting.
Which is, you, over time, can start to
shape it but you don't come in at least to
intubate, you do not come in having
to wear one hat and not another.
And you'll actually get an opportunity
to wear a lot of different hats, and
see which industries
do you enjoy the most?
What type of work do you
end up enjoying the most?
And, by now, I probably have three or
four different hats that I interchange.
I'm a healthcare expert.
I'm an organizational change expert.
There's a few different hats that I
can wear depending on the context, but
those were built over time and because
that was what I ended up enjoying doing.
But I didn't go insane that's
what I'm going to go do, so.
>> To some extent when you start
can't know what the answer for
you is going to be.
I mean I came in laser focused I
wanted to do economic development,
public sector consulting, and
that's what I wanted to do.
And thankfully I really clicked with the
people at ECG, who do that sort of work,
but I've also had a lot of my colleagues
who joined out of the GSB common,
they not have any interest in retail but
really clicked and
had strong relationships with that client
retail or with what our managing director
in retail and they've now become
partners in the retail practice of ECG.
So, it's so much of it's going to be
driven by the choice that you want to make
and the stuff that excites you and
what you're passionate about.
But it's also going to be about
the people that you meet and
where you build those relationships.
Because, as everybody said earlier on,
in the end, it's a team sport,
it's a people business, and
it's going to be about,
who are you going to want to
work with over the longer term.
Or when we eventually get back to travel,
that cliche of who are you going to
want to be stuck in an airport with
when your flight gets delayed.
And that day to day experiences is really,
I think,
what makes it for a lot of people.
>> Here's a great question.
Can you speak to,
maybe, a moment that you knew you made
the right decision to come to the GSB?
It could be a particular moment,
a class, an interaction, a lecture.
Whatever it might be,
what was that moment for you?
>> For me, something near and
near to my heart from the GSB
is a program we called Talk.
Where two students each
week from each class,
go up in front of their classmates and
share life-defining moments,
things that inspire them,
why they are the way they are,
could be just the essay what matters most.
And I know I gave my personal talk
on January of my first year, so
we had a couple of months under balance,
but we're still settling in and
that feeling afterwards is something
that will stick with me forever.
The incredible support of peers even
some of them were nice and friends.
Some of them were still strangers.
But that feeling of support, of being
held by a room of 200 of your classmates,
just because you've
shared about yourself and
gone to the GSB occurency and
it is around vulnerability and
that's shared throughout the entire
school, throughout the way that we create.
We've talked about touchy feely we
create relationships etc., that.
That moment at the end of my talk was
something I wish I could bottle up.
But I knew in that moment I
was in the right place for
me at the right time for me.
And that is more personal than
professional but it has tied into how I
create professional relationships
with clients across teams, etc.
>> Anyone else wanted to share a moment
when they knew they'd made the right
decision?
>> I can go.
I think I knew it from the moment I
stepped on campus on my first day.
And there were so many moments
during the course of the tears.
We'll share a personal line that's a
recent, so it's not the first moment, but
it's a recent moment.
Is I'm planning my wedding and
as you do that,
you think about who you're
going to invite right?
And a majority of my best friends in
life are now the people who I've met at
Stanford.
And I cannot tell you how much,
like they mean to me.
And, it doesn't always happen but
the people at Stanford
are really like the best people I
personally have met in my life.
And, I can't imagine not
having the experience now so.
>> Any other moments,
classes, interactions?
>> Another one I can
throw out there as well.
I agree like I would second talk,
of course,
others would be throughout the journey
in the Arbuckle leadership
program that I think Jonathan
maybe had mentioned that as well.
And just overall echoing the talk piece,
I think Stanford is just very
good at dealing with emotions.
In a way they asked me to
participate in a roleplay in front
of classmates that we were being
trained to be coaches basically.
And during that roleplay
I was a coachee and
they started nudging me into like,
topics of identity and race and
a ton of like things and
under like crying in front of everybody.
And the fact that it was fine
like it was not a surprise.
It was almost like in whatever I
mentioned of like the room kind
of like holds you in a way.
I think that was like my moment of.
I kind of fit here,
this is a good place to be right now.
>> We, tragically lost three
classmates from my class at Stanford.
And I hesitate to share that
because it's really sad moment.
But honestly the way
the community came around,
it just instantly bonded us like it
happened in the first few weeks of school.
And so, that sticks out to me because
there was that moment where we all looked
at each other and we were like, we're
going to help each other get through this
incredibly difficult time and
from people in my class.
And also the way the school handled it was
like an immediate moment of like, wow,
I'm in the exact right place.
So grateful to this day for how the school
handled that and the people around me.
>> A lot of very moving examples.
I want to be cognizant of the time.
I know we're coming up towards
the end of our session today.
I want to thank our panelists for
sharing your perspectives today and for
all of our attendees I want to thank you,
for your attention as well,
and your interest in Stanford.
We hope that this is just a start
of your Stanford GSB journey.
There are many ways to continue that, and
one that I'd highly recommend, is a site
called MyStanford.mba, if you haven't been
there already Definitely check that out.
There's an opportunity to
create a personalized dashboard
there you can track your
application progress.
It'll tee up courses or club
recommendations that might be of interest
to you or students or alumni who might
I'd have similar interests or profiles.
And it's also just another wonderful
way to find out about other events,
such as the one today.
So again, thank you everyone for
attending.
We will have another poll
question that is popping up too.
And we appreciate your responses on that.
Thanks to our attendees and our panelists.
Wish you all the best and good luck on
your journey into a career in consulting.
[MUSIC]